I know you're close obviously with your
parents but you took your mom to to
London is that right yeah no big deal
that's nice something that's the nice
thing to do is she my mom loved it we
she's been wanting to go to London her
whole life and so we went and it was so
fun we flew in on the day of breakfast
so everybody was like shocked and sad
but the dollar was so strong we which
you we had high tea and then we went on
a Jack the Ripper tour and right when he
was talking about the disembowelment
towards the end we noticed that our
bowels were a little queasy and it
wasn't from the murder it was from the
high tea yeah
murder toys yeah yeah you're back at
murder again you really do light up a
room you know
[Applause]
girl she was the light of our lives
[Laughter]
there I know your mom loves she's right
she's really into like the Royals and
isn't she's always been right she loves
the royal family who doesn't it's just
such a peace peaceful image to watch
their faces in all the murder yeah you
know it's like you go all the internet
it's like murder murder murder then you
see like Keith Middleton and you're like
ah that's nice they're so big you think
the Kardashians are big because they
take our minds off of laughter that's
the strangest thing I've heard in such a
long time genius that yeah I have to ask
you I know you brought your mom has been
obsessed with the Royals for a long time
yeah and you were gonna prove it because
you have your mom's diary from when you
were a baby is that right yeah and this
is real this is not a bit this is a real
thing yeah yes I am we're gonna make
time he can't tell me what to do she's
America's Sweetheart yeah
we've always got time for the most
popular girl in town damn I don't think
we have time now oh that's alright
we do it next to Andy you tell me what
to do I don't care alright you bring us
next time that we get to come on the
show again
alright someday you guys will get to
read from this diary it's pretty cool
alright gonna get cut talking about what
is wrong with you it'll get viewed all
the time after the murder yeah
you
you